efectivamente la federación que ha
terminado el contrato de coordinar ya
que había toda una comisión a la que se
le había encomendado audicionar las
partes en todo este asunto y según lo
que nos dijo el presidente de la
federación con quien hablamos hace unos
instantes decía que lo que se había lo
que se había resaltado luego de ese
trabajo de esa comisión es que en
realidad había una fractura con las
jugadoras que tampoco estaban los
niveles de alto nivel esas expectativas
de alto nivel por parte de este equipo
tampoco se estaban dando y que toda la
situación había llegado digamos a un
punto de no retorno y que a pesar de que
entendía muy bien que
pues había hecho un trabajo bastante
serio en realidad se necesitan otras
cosas sobre todo teniendo en cuenta los
dos objetivos importantes que se ha
fijado la federación uno es el mundial
de fútbol ahora este verano que se
jugará en Australia y a Nueva Zelanda y
los Juegos Olímpicos de París el próximo
año hay que cabe Resaltar que cuando
Ellos hablan de esa ruptura con las es
algo que ya venía dándose desde mucho
tiempo atrás entendiendo también por
ejemplo que el año pasado
por fuera de la lista de convocadas para
la Euro 2022 que se disputó en
Inglaterra a la capitana a monchino Ovi
quien había sido la capitana durante el
Mundial de fútbol que se jugó justamente
aquí en 2019 Pero también
es la goleadora de este equipo y desde
entonces ninguna de ellas dos ha vuelto
a jugar así que en todo caso todo esta
ruptura venía ya dándose cada vez más
con esos digamos esa forma de pronto muy
dura de indiac con una estafa muy
reducido también no tiene director
técnico adjunto desde hace más de un año
una persona que decidió dejar ese cargo
y ella no nombró una nueva mano derecha
Así que son bastantes dificultades Eso
sí cabe Resaltar que la federación dice
estar molesta por la manera como las
jugadoras dieron a conocer su
descontento y que esperan que esto no
vuelva a producirse en el futuro